this is a prototype and they tried to
vaccinate everybody on Earth with it and
that's unconscionable right we should be
celebrating these things uh in the
academic literature and we should be
trying to figure out how they might be
properly targeted so that they don't
cause the immune system to attack cells
throughout the body
but we skipped all that we just decided
they were safe and effective almost by
decree and went around injecting people
irrespective of their need for them
which you know yeah and what I find even
more shocking Brett is even once this
information was clearly available that
there was a signal of harm they didn't
just carry on with the rollout they
coerced and mandated it I mean that is
just beyond belief that can only be
described as being rooted in psychopathy
as far as I'm concerned there's only
there's no other explanation
it not only that but the protections
from such a thing are utterly specific
hard one gains at the end of the
Holocaust we went through the effort of
writing the Nuremberg code and
establishing the absoluteness of one's
right to informed consent
and in this case we have
proprietary ingredient lists we have uh
adverse event signals which are being
systematically ignored there's no way
patients are deciding to take these
things on the basis of information and
what's more once you coerce them then
it's not consent so we're violating
we're violating Nuremberg
out in the open and that my sense is
look anytime you're violating Nuremberg
something important is going on and it
ought to call the attention of anybody
who takes the idea of civilization
seriously in the first place
this is one of the things we don't do
informed consent is as close to sacred
as we get
absolutely and we're not going to
improve you know that one of the things
I'm a big proponent of is is
evidence-based medicine and there's a
very elegant analytical and teaching
framework we use to practice
evidence-based medicine and that
incorporates our individual clinical
expertise as a doctor the best available
evidence and then last but not least is
taking into consideration individual
patient preferences and values and at
the heart of that is share this is
making informed consent and if you don't
incorporate those three components then
you are not going to achieve
um in the you know uh optimal patient
outcomes
you know treating an illness managing
risks reducing suffering and actually
everything to be honest for me um I
think comes back to our doctors actually
practicing
evidence-based medicine in in order to
ethical evidence-based medicine
it's improved patient outcomes and I
think many unwittingly are not I think
most doctors want to do the right thing
they go into profession for those
reasons
um but they are being deceived by this
powerful corporate entity and um uh and
then and then you know again doesn't
take a rocket scientist to figure out if
you're making clinical decisions on
biased and corrupted information Brett
they're best you're going to get some
optimal outcomes for the patient the
worse you're going to do harm
so actually in a way the solutions are
quite simple
you know from an intellectual point of
view they're not complicated they're
very simple but um those Solutions those
Simple Solutions are a challenge to uh
the profit making you know businesses of
uh of um of these multinational
corporations I had a conversation with
Pierre Corey uh
I can't remember exactly when it was it
was one of the ones that YouTube took
down before demonetizing this channel
um and anyway we talked about the shift
that once upon a time doctors were
inherently scientists they had fewer
tools at their disposal but what they
did have was the ability to see patterns
in their community in an individual
patient over time and that extrapolating
from those patterns to a proper course
of treatment you know trying things that
would seem like they should work
discovering that they do or don't and
you know building up a protocol based on
the actual impact on patients makes a
tremendous amount of sense and what what
has happened and what went into
overdrive during covid seems to have
been this idea that medicine is about
proclamations from on high handed down
and administered by doctors it's
effectively turned them into
uh technicians Downstream of a an opaque
process and it's almost impossible for
me to imagine how that could go right
yes I think another way of describing is
that evidence-based medicine has been
hijacked towards become an illusion
because that other component which I
didn't discuss in detail is this best
available evidence certainly over the
years seems to have become more and more
distorted and biased and you know to
cite John ainidis who you know is
Professor of medicine at Stanford and
probably one of the smartest guys on the
planet as a medical scientist
um you know he published a paper in plus
one in 2001 I think which was why most
published research findings are false
yeah um and and you know if one starts
from that position understanding what
all the biases are in terms of
um you know the best available evidence
then it's easier to understand why we're
not getting good patient outcomes or the
best patient outcomes but also the
solutions are there you know and
ultimately the solutions mean Brett the
the drug industry
um although they can develop drugs or
devices or whatever else
they shouldn't be allowed to test them
and they shouldn't be allowed to then
hold on to the data because that's
really where the the heart of the
problem lies in clinical decision making
they design the trials they rig the
trials they do their own analyzes they
um Co-op scientists you know they fund
institutions and and and all of that
ultimately results in what you described
earlier on is that we all get an
exaggeration
on the benefits and safety of
medications
um you know I would say that people the
default position needs to be now this
all industry-sponsored studies need to
be seen as marketing until proven
otherwise
so I wanted to call attention to
something else that I uh I hear in your
description of what's taken place and I
uh I've also been tracking it separately
in my own life and work
which is a disconnect between
the short-term implications of things
and the long term and I find that in a
regulatory sense
when we are good we are good at spotting
short-term connections that are very
direct
and we often over extrapolate to the
long term and we you know for example
you point out was the number one in 800
serious adverse event risk in the
randomized controlled trials
but that one in 800 is
over a tiny number of months two months
so there is no if one has the sense that
okay one in 800 that's bad but it's not
catastrophic that we have no idea what
fraction of people were injured from
that trial in the long run and what's
more
uh our ability to discover it is
obscured by another little feature of
the Pharma game
Pharma loves to trigger a an ethical
provision
in the in the protocols which says that
if a drug is sufficiently efficacious in
a trial it is immoral not to give it to
those in the control group and so if it
can arrange to hit that Mark then it can
obliterate the control group and make it
impossible to figure out what the
long-term impact of these treatments is
because in fact the control group only
existed for a short period of time
so I guess
um you know this this is the thing that
stuck out for Heather and me at the
beginning of this was even if these
things are highly effective at
preventing the transmission of covid
which they turned out not to be there is
the danger that they will create harms
10 years down the road which we will be
completely unaware of until those
patterns emerge and
um that's always the case we always have
to be cautious that what we are doing is
on the basis of comparatively short time
series and our information gets better
over time but only if we collect the
data yeah Brad no 100 I'm glad you've
raised this point so I think that 1 800
figure is probably a significant
underestimate of the true serious
Adverse Events because that was really
only in the first two months and then
they you know they then um unblinded
people in the control group now one of
what could also be the case historically
well well a couple of things one is
when these trials are designed it's in
Farmers interest to try and show that
the safety is
as best as it can possibly be through
the trial and often that means that they
will recruit people who are probably
lower risk of having Adverse Events
because they know they figured stuff out
early on whether it's through animal
studies or whatever else who is likely
to be least likely to develop a
significant adverse effect so that we
have to throw into the equation as well
then you've got what as you've suggested
what could be going on further down the
line
expand certainly I think there is more
than enough evidence now to suggest from
a coronary artery disease perspective
and I by the way manage patients as well
who have had a rapid acceleration of
coronary artery disease where we've done
corneannigrams routinely and suddenly a
mild narrowing within the space of nine
months or a year suddenly severe which
doesn't happen usually that quickly and
the only common denominator is two doses
of Pfizer or moderna vaccine right so
it's accelerating one of the mechanisms
is it's accelerating accelerating
carniotic disease which means and this
seems to happen you know quite quickly
within the first few months we will
probably continue to see a rise in
people having heart attacks or being
diagnosed with ischemic heart disease
for years because of this
um and therefore and even Cardiac Arrest
my father for example
he wouldn't have been picked up in the
trial because and I must add that my
case study or description of what
happened to my dad was in the
peer-reviewed paper which was then
accepted by the peer reviewers as well
as a reasonable explanation for what
happened to him my father had his
cardiac arrest six months after the
second dose of the fisa vaccine
and I described that as a case study and
I said that this these are type of case
studies that would often you know would
be it's it's a way of explaining complex
information that may be missed from a
randomized control trial so here's an
example of that and other patients I've
seen as well
um certainly
um can have effects you know a few
months after the vaccine which which
through the history seemed to ultimately
be attributed to the vaccine so I think
um it's probably a gross underestimate I
think the other thing that's worth
mentioning historically with
pharmacovigilance data
um it's thought that a serious Adverse
Events are reported
are actually only uh um represent about
10 of the true cases
and Norway have been pretty good at
looking at their recoverment of vars or
the other card scheme and they found
certainly early on
um what constituted uh whether there was
a doctor entry for a serious adverse
event which was very clearly defined as
something that was life-changing or
resulted in hospitalization or
disability that was about one in 926.
after two doses of the fisa vaccine
so that could again probably that's
still an underestimate of what's going
on because many conditions and certain
things that are going on in the
community that are serious would not
come out through the reporting scheme
and therefore I think it's much much
worse
yeah much much worse is uh
is essentially certain I mean you know
as you point out your father would not
have been counted as an adverse event uh
because he would have been long after
the trial was over and
um so we have to ask ourselves
how many of these things are being
captured at all and to the extent that
we have a completely unprecedented
um signal yeah and so I think one of the
thing that we've talked about informed
consent and and something I wanted to
highlight my paper is that if we if we
accept the least uh of the risk of a
serious adverse event let's just say is
one in 800 probably that's an
underestimate what's the benefit and
what I try to do using actual real world
data looking at hospitalization and
deaths in the UK during the Delta wave
last year
was to break down by age group and by
the way this is not corrected for
confounding factors so we know for
example unvaccinated certainly the UK
and maybe in the US tend to come from
low socioeconomic groups and are
generally higher risk of death from
covert anyway so this is still best case
scenario but what we found is if you're
over 80
um the vaccine during a wave during the
Delta wave the vaccine would give you a
benefit of 1 in 230 in terms of
preventing a covert death it became one
in 520 if you're aged between 70 and 80
but during Omicron
you know from the first few months this
year you're talking about having to
vaccinate 7 300 people over the age of
80.
to prevent one covered death
and you know that is a number when I
tell patients that
you know I I've I do this in my practice
when I discuss other pills like statin
drugs for example
most of those patients would say no
thank you Doctor that's not for me right
yeah we try and introduce informed
consent with the best available evidence
most people would not take uh certainly
anymore would not take this vaccine
yeah it's a slam dunk if you're talking
about needing to inoculate 7 000 people
with a substance that causes a serious
adverse event in 1 in 800 inside of two
months with no information on how many
people are ultimately impacted you know
many months down the road where the
connection uh may be lost then that is
you know obviously medically
counter-indicated
um
uh so yeah it's and you know the certain
things stick out about this program this
is clearly not epidemiological or
medical in nature because if it was
you would Age stratify the
recommendation
right now again I don't think either you
or I think anybody should be getting
these mRNA inoculants
um but if you were let's say that you
calculated differently you would still
think the older you were the more likely
you were to get a benefit that could
justify facing the risks and there's no
way you'd be pointing them at children
but the fact is
we've got some sort of cartoon policy in
which inoculation good you know that
that's basically the point and
um
uh it's not surprising the Pharma would
take that perspective what is
maybe somewhat more surprising is that
our Public Health officials would but of
course as you point out the degree to
which their funding is coming from
exactly the people who benefit from such
a policy makes that less surprising
the fact that
the trials are run by the companies that
have this perverse incentive is of
course a jaw-dropping discovery but then
there's even one layer deeper I wonder
what uh if you have thoughts on this
what I learned in uh looking at the RCT
data and evidence from
uh from Pharma was that in fact it's not
even that these companies do the trials
the companies contract the trials to
these companies that run trials as their
business
and the problem with that is that that
constitutes another evolutionary
environment in other words if if the
client is a Pharma company
trying to find out if a drug is safe
enough to administer
well then there's competition between
the uh companies that run the trials to
deliver evidence of safety
they know that because the point is a
drug company doesn't want to spend the
money to test a drug that isn't safe
enough to bring to Market so the desired
answer is clear and all they have to do
is Select for companies that tend to
give them an indicator of safety and the
point is that little industry of people
who run trials for a living
evolves in the direction of finding
safety no matter what the truth is right
it's you can see the psychopathy
evolving you know almost in real time
yeah no it makes sense I hadn't thought
about it from that perspective
and Brett makes complete sense no doubt
if we were to just simply probe the
system in location after location we
would find little surprises like that
that one happens to have become clear in
those cases but how many other places
are there where the system is subtly
biased in the direction of giving us an
indication that drugs are more effective
than they actually are that competitors
are less effective than they actually
are that the drugs are safer than they
actually are right the point is the
whole system is looking for ways to sell
that story and you know I mean you said
it yourself uh you know 20 minutes ago
that effectively any of the stuff
produced by the system should be taken
as uh as PR yeah right as PR it's not
science science is a delicate process
that requires you to actually uh adhere
to the the method and the underlying
philosophy of science and the perverse
it's not robust to perverse incentives
the fact is science requires you to to
actually do it properly
[Music]